hey what's up people of pawnee all right
all right uh in just a minute scarecrow
boat is gonna rock it out please be
patient while we rock out the equipment
setup
the band has had a few different names
over the years we started we were teddy
bear suicide
but then we changed it to mouse rat
then we were god hates figs two doors
down
department of homeland obscurity then we
were three skin
just the tip flames for flames muscle
confusion
nothing rhymes with orange uh then
everything rhymes with orange
andy dwyer experience a d and the d bags
the andy andy andes
radwagon five skin foreskin nothing
rhymes with
bloring death of a scam artist razor
dick puppy pendulum awesome pendulum
penis pendulum and real suicide
angel snack
uh jet black pope punch face champions
ninja dick
we went back to mouse rat and now we are
scarecrow
god when i hear myself say scarecrow
boat out loud i kinda hate it
[Music]
andy i need you to write a memorial song
something like candle in the wind but
5 000 times better easy hey if you want
a song from andy dwyer lead singer of
mouse
rat you should know he doesn't get out
of bed for less than a thousand dollars
we can give him 50 bucks
sold next we have a special
musical tribute by mr andy dwyer
what's 5 000 times better than a candle
in the wind
this song is called 5 000
candles in the wind
you trade your legs for angel's
wings and once we've all said
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
sebastian
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i mean that sucked didn't it
maybe if you sang it like louis
armstrong maybe
yeah i mean here's the thing though
who is that my problem is i don't know
how to tell if we're doing good because
when you play a rock show it's really
easy to know if you're doing great
because
chicks will flash their boobs at you
when you're up on stage
you're like oh that must sounded pretty
good
but i can't if that happens here my eyes
will fall out of my head and i'll die
i have finished writing leslie's
campaign anthem it's called catch your
dream
and it's amazing it's kind of like we
are the world except
i actually think it could have a real
impact on society
i never thought i'd say this to you son
but you may be overthinking this the
song has to be perfect ron
okay leslie trusted me with it i can't
come up with some brilliant political
idea can i
this is the only way i can help maybe if
i hit my head against ground
that's worked before leslie is gonna
love it i promise
no offense ron but what do you know
about music
hmm take a walk
clear your head i bet it does you some
good
all right guys here's the deal we got to
completely start over
i wrote a new song it's called the
promise of tomorrow's wings it's
brilliant about a billion times better
than catch your dreams which i realize
now
sucks ass hey chuck go ahead and just uh
delete everything all right
hold on chuck just listen to the song
one more time
and then make a decision
where's that saxophone coming from i
don't know i don't know the first thing
about music
oh is that a new mix sounds way better
see
just needed to clear your head hey
you guys who is this this looks just
like
wow that was loud
i would like to introduce one of the
hottest bands in pawnee
ladies and gentlemen i give you mouse
rat
i know that life is
oh hey everybody my name is andy dwyer
you probably know me as the
artist formerly known as the lead singer
of mouse rat
well after tonight you'll only know me
as the former
artist formerly known as the lead singer
of mouse rat i'm retiring
from music this is my swan song
once there was a golden swan swan of a
man
now that swan's name was andy started a
rock and roll band
he made incredible nachos that everybody
claimed they loved
and then the bandmates [ __ ] him over
with the massive rock and roll
show this is my swan
song watch me fly i'm gonna find a place
where i can be
the beautiful duckling i always was
[Music]
inside
[Music]
okay sex is cool got that i say we
finish
on drunk off our asses and i think we
should do sex in space
it's 20 minutes long but it's really
good babe i don't think you should play
any of those songs for a group of
six-year-olds
well wait six-year-olds did you book us
a gig at a kid's party
you said we were playing at a festival
you said dave grohl might be there dave
grohl
might be there i don't know he might be
anywhere the guy's awesome and he's
unpredictable
no no i'm not playing for a bunch of
screaming kids mousetraps are rock band
we're not the wiggles
come on i'm sick of all the drama with
this band
i quit i'm going back to rabbinical
school umbilical school
rivers come back rivers don't do this
hey shaq might be there
you missed the band no i mean i love
that i'm johnny karate
now but being part of a band that's just
that's rock and roll man
joining us now for our finale legendary
local band
please welcome mouserat you guys are
closing this
well how about this unity concert huh
i love this town so much and i'm just so
proud to live here
and we're gonna close tonight out with a
tribute to pawnee's
greatest treasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once we've all said
goodbye
you take a running leap and you learn
[Applause]
[Music]
is
ladies and gentlemen mr duke silver
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you